hello Hannah welcome to intelligence squ
hi thanks very much for having me well
it was my pleasure I am I'm delighted
we're going to be able to get to talk
about this book not the end of the world
uh whether I should hold it on this side
or it's probably going to be mirrored
copy so yes yeah you go you go for it
so I love reading the book um I Margaret
Atwood also loved reading the book so
that's probably more important than the
fact that I love reading it but I did
love reading it it actually took me back
to um it's going to sound rather strange
it took me back to my my early days of
of courting because my my wife was an
environmentalist and uh when I met her
uh she had studied this environmental
master's degree and all her friends had
studied this environmental master's
degree and so they're all
environmentalists and they're all
talking about food miles on organic food
and quite a lot of what you were talking
about in the book basically just
reminded me of me going well yes that
sounds that sounds
you know very plausible but is that
actually what the data show so we're
going to we're going to get geeky we're
going to talk about saving the world
we're going to talk about the data um
and I I will try not to talk anymore
about how I met my wife because that's
of no interest to it to anybody um so
just tell us first of all what's the big
picture what what is this book about so
I think to start with I think the
concept seems quite bold but hopefully
it'll make sense um my my core argument
in the book is that I think we have the
opportunity to be the first generation
to be sustainable now when you first
think of that that sounds quite
controversial because I'm implying that
no generation before has been
sustainable but the reason I make that
argument is um historically in uh
societies might have been
environmentally sustainable so they
weren't degrading the environment for
future
Generations but in order to do that they
often had very low living standards so
an example I give is that for most of
human history about half of children
died before reaching puberty so living
standards were often low and what's
happened over the last few centuries is
that human living conditions have really
massively improved across the world on
many many metrics but that has come at
the cost of the environment we've burned
fossil fuels for energy we've cut down
forests to grow more food and so we've
we've we've been balanced one way and
we've tipped the other way and the core
argument of the book is I think we have
the opportunity if we make the right
decisions and get moving that we can
achieve both of these things at the same
time we can provide a good life for
everyone without degrading the
environment so you you phrase it there
in a in a very practical way and you you
come across in the book as a very
practical person like these are things
that we can do um these are the steps
that we need to take um there is there
is a much more
optimistic framing in your book than in
most of the books I I read about the
environment though I mean that the maybe
the clues in the title not the end of
the world you one of the first things
you say is look it's you we are not
actually doomed and it's not helpful to
think that we are doomed so why was that
one of the first points that you wanted
to make that that the Dooms Day thinking
isn't helpful because I think I've been
and I've done my background is
environmental science I did that all
through University um and at the end of
my degree there I really did feel this
kind of level of Doom of I've done I've
done all this I've done all the work
behind the scenes and but now I feel
kind of incapable to change things
because I really felt like nothing could
change and these problems weren't
solvable and I think since then I've
just seen that feeling grow over time
like I know from the emails I get from
people that they really feel like these
are big problems but there's just
nothing we can do about it I see it
often in headlines I I I I'm seeing
increasing levels of Doom around me and
I think that's not particularly
constructive to us moving forward if we
step back and say we give up there's
nothing we can do about it then that's a
Surefire way of making sure that we
don't fix these problems so my core
argument in the book is we need to push
back and we need to say yes these
problems are solvable let's get
going the book reminded me in some ways
of of a couple of other uh books that
I'm sure you know uh one was uh Steven
pinker's Enlightenment now and step
pinker's book refers a lot to the data
from the our world in data website you
know which which you are you know you're
one of the the main moving forces behind
that website uh and the other book it
reminds me of is uh Hans rosling's
factfulness um and I know a lot of
people have read those books so tell me
a little bit about how you would compare
your book to them what's different about
what you're saying and and what are the
commonalities so I think the
commonalities is the our core argument
is if you step back to look at the data
you often get a very different picture
from what you would build just by
looking news headlines and having a a
rather narrow view of the world I think
where it's really different is that I
only really focus on these human
measures so child mortality poverty
maral mortality um and the Really first
chapter of the book and the reason I do
that is because I think as
environmentalists we often just don't
get that picture of what's actually
happening to human well-being so I think
it's important to get that across but in
the rest of the book it's completely
focused on our environmental problems
which I think Hans rosling and Steven
Pinker did much less
yeah so so you you've you're looking at
the same data and you reach the same
conclusion which is things are great as
long as this is in some way sustainable
or at least as long as we as long as it
can become sustainable before we degrade
the environment irreparably and then
then I guess then the the what's radical
about your say about what you're saying
is actually we can make this sustainable
we have got some big problems but uh
they're they're fixable and we've had
big problems in the past and we've fixed
them yeah I think I see us as at the
moment a bit of a Crossroads where we've
as you've said all of these Trends are
largely getting better for most people
in the world and we're at a kind of fork
on the road where we can go down a path
where these continue to improve and we
manage to fix our environmental problems
at the same time or we don't fix our
environmental problems and actually you
have the issue that some of these measur
could start to regress hunger could
start to regress deaths from natural
disasters could go upwards there are a
range of human metrics which could be
impacted by our continued environmental
damage and yeah as you see like when you
step back to look at the data there are
obviously really really worrying signs
in a lot of the data but there are also
stories of success and I think it's
important to bring those stories of
success out so that we get this
understanding that yes these are Big
challenges but we have solved many of
them in the past and we can continue to
do that so let's talk a bit about
uh air pollution uh and because there
were some there some key success stories
there and and I want to talk about what
that teaches us or what it doesn't teach
us about how we can deal with climate
change so one of the the really I mean
I'm a nerd so I know some of the stuff
in your book uh and yet I kept coming
across things I actually that one I
didn't know or I've never seen it that
way so one of the the points that you
make in the book that surprised me is
you take you know one of the the cities
with a reputation for the worst air
pollution today which is Delhi and you
compare it to Victorian London and
Victoria in London was worse uh and
that's that really took me by surprise
so we we had an air pollution problem
and we've done an awful lot to fix it in
uh in the UK so how did that happen was
that regulation is that a technological
change what's going on there yeah
there's maybe like other air pollution
related problems we can come on to but
the local air pollution in London yeah I
think we have we kind of forget that
many of our cities in the rich world
today you go back a century and they
were extremely polluted like London is
one example I'm in Edinburgh so we were
called the old rcky so really polluted
city London was the Big Smoke and it was
the Big Smoke because smoke was filled
there there and there are stories of um
the big uh London Smog Where I mean you
literally people were walking down the
street they couldn't see in front of
them they were shuffling along trying to
feel for the curve because the the air
was so polluted and a big driver of that
was coal burning so one like now we
think of coal burning as just producing
electricity in a power plant but
historically we would often just burn
coal in our houses and it would go out
the chim chimney and and into the
streets um so you had this like really
thick blanket of you're younger than me
I remember this I grew up I grew up in a
coal mining area in darbishire and yeah
I had uh you know we had a
I think we had we had a gas fire we
didn't have a Coal Fire but friends of
mine had a had a cal bunker and had a
Coal Fire that's that's what you did
yeah so the yeah so what some of the
success stories there is one is just
moving away from coal that the UK has
made amazing progress on on moving away
from coal we basically don't burn any
coal anymore um which has happened
actually very quickly in the space of a
few decades um we've put in really
strict uh uh pollution controls on power
plants so that's government policy
another big source of air pollution has
been cars on the road and we often look
outside now and think our our streets
must be the most polluted they've ever
been look at the number of cars spewing
toxic fumes out the back but um car
manufacturers actually have had
increasingly strict regulations on how
much of this these pollutants they can
admit and and if you look at the data
you just see that pollution has
significantly decreased yeah I was quite
struck by the fact that there's this
enormous fuss about the ultra low
emission Zone in London and I guess I'd
kind of assumed that you had to be
basically driving an electric car it's
ultra low emissions but no just like you
can drive a modern diesel car into
London it's fine it's perfectly
perfectly legal perfectly within the
limits of the zone so it just reminded
me or or underlined to me that you can
have what a lot of people regard as
Draconian regulations but actually
modern cars are so clean that they meet
those standards yeah and that's applies
to local Air pollutants but it also
applies to to CO2 emissions um so cars
have also just become increasingly
efficient over time such that uh you can
also Drive declines in CO2 emissions for
these Technologies now there's it's not
to say the air pollution in our cities
are perfect you know in the UK we still
have at least the estimates are like
tens of thousands of premature deaths
every year it was more in the past and
the point is you can look at this these
Trends and say oh it's possible to make
progress here how can we squeeze out
that last bit so we don't have tens of
thousands still dying yeah now you said
you wanted to talk about other forms of
of air pollution um you have a couple of
case studies in the book you talk about
acid rain what we did about acid rain
you talk about the ozone hole what we
did about the ozone hole so just give us
the quick prey there and then and does
that tell us something about how to cope
with climate change or are they are they
false
parallels um I think the the differ
there is I think you can use the local
Air Pollution example to show that it's
possible to make progress I think some
people would push back and say well okay
like countries can do that at a local
level because they care about their own
people but the struggle is when you try
to work together in international um
collaboration but the ozone layer and
acid Rin problem are like perfect
examples of where countries really did
work together often not really in their
personal interests but realized that
there was a collective problem and the
oone whole life I don't remember it like
it was before my time but um he's so
young so
young but I mean these were I
remember I having like a really old man
here but I remember the acid rain I
remember the ozone hole I remember when
we were really really worried about this
I was born in the the early 1970s so I
was a I was a school kid in the 80s we
were we were really worried about this
stuff in the 1980s and yet we you know
these problems I think I don't think
it's complacent to say we've basically
solved both those problems
yeah I mean the ozone whole the gases
the CFCs that c that depleted the ozone
um layer we've basically reduced them by
more than 99% now so we've kind of done
the job of stopping those emissions the
ozone hole is still there and it will
take decades to close but really there's
nothing more we can do about it we've
stopped emitting the gases we just need
to wait for it to heal and the same with
acid drain across Europe and North
America like our emissions of sulfur
dioxide which which is what causes acid
Rin
are many countries have reduced
emissions by more than 90% so we really
emit very little of these gases now so
you could essentially say yes these two
problems we've solved and we just don't
really hear about them anymore yeah so
the the
argument So that obviously suggests hey
you know we can solve these problems we
can get together these were both these
were all Collective action problems and
so is climate change so you know
basically it's the same thing just a bit
bigger I guess the
counterargument would be um I remember I
remember talking to Thomas shelling the
Nobel prize winning Economist shortly
after he he won the Nobel Memorial prize
and he is a game theorist he's
interested in Collective active uh
Collective action
problems and he he actually said CL he
felt that climate change was more like
the Marshall Plan he was actually
involved in negotiating the Marshall
Plan way back in the
1940s um you know it's about burden
sharing it's about who is going to who's
going to stump up the cost and who's not
it's a much more expensive problem um
and he was worried because with the
Marshall Plan you have the US basically
sitting over it setting deadlines and
saying you guys have got to agree uh as
to you know who's going to pay who's
going to get the benefits and you know
we don't have that same time time
constraints with climate change uh at
least we don't have an artificial
deadline we don't have someone imposing
that
deadline and then maybe we won't we
won't really get round to solving it
you're more optimistic than that one way
or another you you think we have made a
lot of progress yeah and I don't think
it's going to be easy and I don't think
it's a per the ozone problem or the
acidrain problem is a perfect parallel I
think climate change is just much harder
to solve so I largely agree with his
analysis there do you want to take a
moment to to explain to everyone why
it's a harder problem than say ozone
yeah so the problem with ozone is that
we were using these specific gases cfc's
chlorofluorocarbons in refrigerators
deodorants a small subset of of stuff
that we used and we got to the point
where there was just basically a basic
substitute you could just take the cfc's
out and put something else in in its
place and initially it was maybe a
little bit more expensive but it was
kind of a one for one substitution
within a really small number of goods so
once we did that the problem was largely
solved the problem with climate change
is like we literally need to change
everything we need to change the way we
produce energy um the way we move around
the food we eat um the way be B stuff
like it's full economy wide problem so I
think that's part of the reason why it's
so much harder yeah what gives me you
yeah so how's it going what gives you
hope
um we're still very far off track from
where we need to be but what gives me
optimism that we have a shot of actually
tackling this is we've actually made
quite a lot of progress in the last
decade it sounds unbelievable but we
actually have so we're currently on
track for around two and a half degrees
that's kind of the median estimate of
where our current policies are taking us
now that's very bad that's global
average temperatures relative to the
long run outage industrial where we're
going to end up I mean that's not where
we are now but that's where it looks
like will'll end up yeah by the end of
the century yeah and is that bad sorry
sorry to ask the dumb question is that
is that a problem that's bad that's
really bad M um we've set targets of
trying to keep temperatures below
1.5° and well below 2° if not we won't
reach the 1.5° target we're going to go
past 1.5° so in that regard I'm not this
like crazy Optimist um I think if you'd
asked me a decade ago I would have said
two two degrees was completely
unfeasible as well I'm becoming slightly
more optimistic that we can get close to
that range although we're currently
headed for 2.5
yeah and the reason for that and the
reason I'm optimistic and I think what
maybe goes slightly against the quote
you gave earlier is that I think if it
was true a decade ago that it was very
expensive to tackle climate change right
if you look at any of the Technologies
we need to switch to so solar or wind or
electric vehicles they were all far more
expensive than coal or gas or a petrol
car yeah so it really was like are you
willing to sacrifice the economy and put
put your money on the line and in order
to solve this and a lot of countries
just weren't yeah I was talking to just
for context I was talking to shelling in
2005 he had been writing about this
problem since I think the
1970s and you know as as you say as of
2005 that's solar I mean solar is just a
pipe dream right it's yeah that's not
that's not a real option is it but now
it is yeah so over the last decade the
price of Solar has fallen by 90% the
price of wind has fallen by 70% electric
cars are starting to re reach price
parity with a petrol car um so your
solar and wind are now the cheapest
Technologies we can we can put in
instead of coal or gas so I think
regardless of climate change many
countries will actually just start to do
this because it's the cheapest option so
I think we need to stop framing this as
a are you willing to sacrifice the
economy in order to solve climate change
because I think that's a false dichotomy
and that's why I'm a bit more optimistic
now than I was a decade ago
yeah are you worried about um solving
the intermittency problem because
batteries I mean batteries are got a lot
cheaper but batteries don't solve
everything you know that the classic you
know what happens at you know 5:30 in a
December evening everyone comes home
Northern Hemisphere it's the wind's not
blowing the sun's not shining it's cold
how how do you solve that problem with
you know without burning carbon so I
think that it's a big challenge but I
think it's a solvable problem um the the
the intermittency problem is different
on different time scales so for you know
evening out like Peaks throughout the
day on the basis of like hours batteries
work well for longer term storage you
might be looking at other options such
as hydrogen or we're now talking about
maybe methanol like storing it as a
liquid fuel which is is easier than a
battery over longer time periods um so I
think I think we will have a range of
solutions at different time scales in
order to balance that and then I think
that they are I think on the demand side
we'll actually just change things a lot
I think um like a problem you might see
is if we all move to electric vehicles
the problem you'll get is in the evening
everyone will come home they'll start
cooking they'll turn on the heating
they'll start charging the electric
vehicle I think what you're going to get
is a very different electricity system
where pricing will often operate and and
go with when Supply is highest so you
get really cheap electricity when the
sun is shining or the wind's blowing and
I think we'll actually start to adapt to
to that so you'll shift your electric
car charging to a time when it's not
Peak demand for example yeah and
probably to to help people imagine this
it's more likely that your car will do
that you'll plug your car in and your
car car will check the internet and go
this is expensive I'm actually going to
sell I'm going to I'm not going to
charge I'm actually going to discharge
I'm going to sell my electricity back to
the grid uh and then when the wind
starts blowing again sudden electricity
is cheap then I'm going to charge up and
you know you could you'll be able to
program your car you'll say find the
cheapest price or charge up at any cost
and you know you won't be constantly
having to think about this as a as a
consumer yeah I think I think it's a big
challenge but I think what people don't
appreciate is that there are a lot of
smart people already doing this on the
National Grid like the fact that your
supply and demand is fluctuating all the
time even on a fossil fuel based system
and it nearly always works um so there's
really smart people working on this
balancing all the time and the people I
spoke to that work for National Grids
they are pretty confident that this is a
solvable problem now not long ago are
you a park Runner Hannah do you do park
run uh I've done a few I like I really
like running I just don't really do park
run don't really do park run well I only
do park run that's my only source of
running not long ago I did a size parkr
where you basically run up the coast of
suffk pass this massive nuclear power
station and back um and I guess there's
two types of runners in the world those
that are delighted to run past the
nuclear power station and those those
that are less than happy about it um
would you would you be happy to run past
a nuclear power station would you be
happy if there were more nuclear power
stations for us to run past yeah I think
I'm I think it's like a very contentious
subject but I'm pro- nuclear as much as
I'm Pro renewable
um my general or or from from from
looking at the data I think there's lots
of concerns around safety and I think
when you actually break down the data in
the book I I look at like number of
deaths per unit of electricity produced
and we've had a few big nuclear
accidents I think more people people
assume more people died in those
accidents than actually did but when you
look at the numbers nuclear it's just
very clear nuclear is much safer than
fossil fuels you have a a pretty that's
without factoring in climate change
that's just looking at the the people
who die as a result of kind of the the
mining of the coal and or are we
including the deaths from local Air
Pollution what are we including in that
fact in that calculation yeah we're
including Supply chains and the mining
and the big one the big one for fossil
fuels is air pollution we're not
factoring in climate change so if you
also factored in climate change fossil
fuels would be even worse so for me it's
this
um less of a framing of are you going to
go for solar and wind or are you going
to go for nuclear it's how can we move
away from fossil fuels as quickly as
possible and I'm pretty much Pro
anything that helps us get there faster
so there's there's lots of different
reasons you might or might not want to
buy uh inst stall nuclear whether it's
cost or uh reconstru uh construction
time um so there's lots of decisions
about whether you want to build a new
one what I definitely don't think we
should do is shut down our existing ones
because we're just shooting ourselves in
in the foot when we install Renewables
we'll start to be replacing the existing
nuclear when we should really be
replacing the fossil fuels yeah I I want
to talk some more about various uh
environmental issues that you discuss in
the book I mean there's so it's so fun
it's so interesting it's really
inspiring before I do that I wanted to I
take a step sideways
what you do again and again in the book
is say look here's a here's an
issue what's going on let's look at the
data like how how bad is this how bad is
this in different parts of the world how
bad is this today versus 10 years ago or
50 years ago or 100 years ago let's
actually look at the data the best data
that we have um so just as a really
foundational question um how trustworthy
is that data how much can we believe
those numbers and are you do you feel
that they're all absolutely solid or
there some that you're more worried
about than
others I think I I mean I I try really
hard to make sure I'm only sourcing from
reliable sources I mean you can find
data that would support any argument
that you want in the world probably um I
thought I found a mistake and then I
checked the references and no you you I
didn't um you'll be pleased to hear I'm
relieved
um yeah like the the the sources are
rely on for most of these things like
the the data is pretty good pretty solid
like we have good data on co2 emissions
for example we have like reasonable
reconstructions of of air pollution um
emissions um where there's
not really longterm data I try to piece
together an overview from a range of
different sources so if you take air
pollution as the example we have
reasonable reconstructions of emiss of
air pollution um by looking at the
amount of fuel we're burning and where
we're burning it Etc um for the last
years or so we don't have a lot of data
previous to there so when it gets to
that stage I tried to understand what
air pollution might have been like a bit
more a bit further in the past and we
can't use data for that but we can use
archaeological evidence so in the book I
reference like um mummy like lung tissue
you can see that it's actually there's
been
air pollution there or looking at
historical anecdotes um where I think I
quot Markus really is the saying he was
so glad to get out of Rome because the
air was filthy and he could like think
clearly again once he left Rome it's
clearly pointing to air pollution is
just not just this modern problem it was
also a problem in the past um so I think
it's a mix of we are really on for most
of the stuff we have like pretty good
solid data and where we don't I try to
be very clear that this is a big data
Gap and we need to fill it and then
trying to piece the story together you
need to draw on different strands of
evidence so let's talk about food if we
can um your special subject I understand
this is what your PhD was actually in as
sustainability of food
um
so there's a story in your book that
just made me
despair of you
sitting next to in a canteen next to an
environmental lecturer I was somebody
who actually had taught you um when you
were a
student and this person ordered the
lamb uh you ordered something vegetarian
and then explained to you that it was
fine to order the lamb because actually
the climate change
impact um wasn't that big because it was
local
lamb
um there's a lot there's so much I have
so many feelings about that story just
tell me tell me why you told that story
and what what it makes you feel I told
that
story I think partly to demonstrate that
even people that work in this field
don't necessarily always get it right
and don't necessarily always base their
decisions based on the data which if you
look at the data would show that like
the inference should have been the other
way around but I think it's also Lambs
lambs are ruminant Lambs are ruminant
you know lamb sheep you know they
they're they they produce a lot of
methane methane is very potent
greenhouse gas you know this is it's bad
it's bad if you're worried about climate
change lamb is not a great thing to eat
and how far the lamb has to travel
before it gets to your plate is is
really a side issue yeah as fraction the
transport component is a fraction of the
impact so like my my number one
recommendation on food if you want to
reduce your carbon footprint is to eat
less meat but specifically beef and lamb
and it doesn't matter whether it's local
your local your local lamb might be
better than lamb from a different
country but it's not
better probably slightly better than I'm
from Wales sorry everyone listening in
Wales but um sorry but but
but but what got me about that that
story was this person was was was
literally their
job to know this right it wasn't just
some random person who was vaguely
worried about the planet and had made a
bad choice because they weren't that
well informed I mean I you I get it you
know we can't can't all know everything
until of course we we read not the end
of the world in which case we do
suddenly know everything in very clear
ways but
like how is it possible to be a lecturer
in environmental sciences and and and to
profess to care about this stuff and to
care enough about this stuff to to be
patronizing you on the topic and yet to
have no idea that's what I I couldn't
quite absorb about that I mean I think
people
just they maybe have one specific area
that they work in or lecture in and then
the rest of the stuff they they base on
intuition and I think the intuitive the
the intuition there seems right and I
get why people make that mistake they
imagine transport that means flying or
shipping or a big truck that obviously
emits lots of CO2 therefore the further
it travels the worse it is yeah the very
word food miles is designed I mean it's
very clever marketing it's designed to
remind people of air miles so you
immediately you think this joint of lamb
is like it's basically strapped in first
class being served champagne and warm
nuts on the way over to my plate but of
course it's not how it works right no
it's not and and uh when you look at I
mean food is a massive contributor to
climate change it's around a quarter to
a third of greenhouse gas emissions but
the transport part is only 5% of food
emissions globally nearly all of the
emissions come from land use change so
deforestation and using the land and
Emissions on the farm so when it comes
to remnants as you say it's it's
emitting methane um those are the big
contributors to the F the carbon
footprint of your food it's not about
the distance that's traveled yeah Ian
I'm interested in how poor some people's
intuitions are about this I mean I
suppose my so my instinct as a as an
economist is that
um and this isn't always right but if
something's
cheap it's it it's probably actually not
consuming loads of resources because
resources are expensive now of course
some resources like the capacity of the
atmosphere to absorb carbon dioxide are
underpriced right so so the price
doesn't always tell you about the
resource consumption but as a first
approximation like if something's really
cheap like if they're willing to give
you the plastic bag at the supermarket
for
nothing it's probably not a huge amount
of oil in that plastic bag it probably
didn't take a huge amount of energy to
produce that plastic bag because like
all this stuff costs money um and the
fact that stuff gets FL all over the
world and it's all it shows up in the
supermarket and it's all cheap that sort
of tells me that those transport
networks probably aren't in fact
consuming huge amounts of resources
because if they were consuming huge
amounts of resources all this stuff
would be super expensive um I don't know
maybe that's maybe that's the wrong way
to think about it but that's my that's
my first cut and I I often find that
when I see people who've actually done
the work like you the results are not
often that different from that that very
simple kind of
you know price price guided heuristic
yeah I think that's a good real of fun
when it comes to the transport of the
food the reason that the food the the
the impact of Transport is often not
that big is that most of our the food
that's travels internationally is comes
by ship right they don't fly it because
flying is carbon intensive and and it's
expensive right they're not going to do
that unless they really have to fly it
to you because it's expensive so most of
it's shipped and shipping is actually
has a very low carbon intensity in terms
of travel so most of the stuff that's
coming to you is not flown it's shipped
for that specific reason that it's
actually expensive to fly yeah it is
interesting that the things that people
do get wrong I mean I know what one of
your Inspirations is Hans rosling and
one of the things that Hans rosling
always used to love to do is ask people
questions that they would get
dramatically wrong but you talk about I
mean it's a very kind book you're not
you are not mean about people in the
book you could be mean but you're you're
just you're just better than that Hannah
so it's a very sort of kind generous uh
book just giving people information but
there are some there are things you talk
about in the book that were you inclined
you could be very rude about like
vertical Farms or people's obsession
with plastic straws you you just look at
the the amount of stuff that people put
in in the bin every week and you think
the straw is is the straw really the
issue or yeah so I mean why do we get
this stuff so
wrong
um I actually don't have a good answer
to why we get this stff I mean the
plastic straws I I don't get why we get
that wrong mean just doesn't make any
intuitive sense to me I think there's
some stuff
that it seems a bit more intuitive to me
why people get like I I kind of get the
local food stuff like I I do get it it
seems kind of intuitive there's nice to
think about supporting local businesses
I mean that's all yeah yeah I think
there's other reasons Beyond carbon
footprint why someone might want to buy
a local and that's fine but I think it's
it's uh sad if they do that thinking
that it's much better for the
environment when it's not there's other
examples like people often assume that
organic food is is just automatically
better than non-organic food when
actually the data would suggest
otherwise and again I kind of
intuitively get it it feels green it
feels natural I think that's what our
environmental um kind of inclinations
are built on is like green natural like
no artificial inputs so I think maybe
that part of it comes into it is that we
we have this kind of got feeling of I
often frame it as like this feeling of
like we want to kind of go backwards in
time like we we think this is the B the
past was really sustainable if we could
just get back there where we can have
all had our little farm where we ever
was organic we weren't using all these
Plastics we weren't using all this
energy I think it part of it is maybe
just this drawback to what we imagine
was a very sustainable past yeah yeah uh
one of the things one of the many things
I like about the book I is that you you
know having
often explain to people look this thing
that you're worried about you shouldn't
be worried about this um this thing that
we're doing is not really helping um
this other thing that's going on this is
really helpful you you you're sort of
laying out the facts but then you you
just offer people really practical
advice both in policy terms like this is
what the priorities should be for our
governments and also in you know in
personal terms like when you're making
decisions about the food you eat here's
what you might want to bear in mind
you're not prescriptive but you give
people the information they need to make
the decisions so what advice if I if I
were to come to you and say um look I'm
uh I realize this is a global problem
but I'm worried about the climate I want
to reduce my personal carbon footprint
what are the three things that I should
think about doing that are going to make
the biggest difference oh free that's a
constraint I think part of the issue I
of have two or or 10 if you like I don't
mind no I think I think the fewer the
better I think I think one of the
problems I often have with environmental
messaging on individual action is that
you have books or like a 100 ways to
save the planet and no one has time to
make 100 decisions
I think part of the problem is there's
no prioritization there so if you could
only make five decisions My worry is
that people are really well intentioned
but they make the five decisions which
don't make a difference like the plastic
bag and the plastic straw yeah so the
the f I think the five core things I
would say is one eat less meat
especially beef and lamb that would be
my one recommendation the other big part
of your carbon footprint is is Road
Transport so if you have a car try to
use use it less so walk public transport
cycle if you really need a car an
electric one is definitely better than a
petrol or diesel one the other big one
is another big one is flying that's
obviously a big one primarily for people
in the rich world because most of the
world do not fly um home heating uh so a
big thing there is like one if you can
reduce the temperature slightly but uh a
big thing you can do if you can afford
it is to install a heat pump pump it's
just way better for the environment than
a gas boiler and then another big thing
is um like home energy like if you can
install a solar panel definitely do it I
mean a lot of these are constrained by
finance and living conditions a lot of
them I can't do because I currently rent
a flat so I can't install a heat pump I
could can't put a solar panel on the
roof but I think these are just this the
these probably make up around 80% of
your footprint and if you want to do the
rest great but I don't think we should
do that on the basis that we assume
we're having a massive impact with those
small decisions yeah oh and one one idea
that you mentioned in your book that had
never occurred to me and I was like why
did that never occur to me is hybrid
hybrid Burgers so uh obviously if you're
concerned about animal rights you want
to be vegetarian you're not going to eat
a be beef burger you want to eat
something else but if you're you're
willing to eat some beef but you want to
reduce
the the car footprint it could be you
know part beef part chicken part plant
protein or hybrid Burgers why did I
never think of hybrid Burgers where can
I buy a hybrid Burger are they coming I
think there are a few companies that do
a mix now but I mean you can immediately
see how that would work right like we
need to move away from we need to
globally we need to eat less meat right
yeah and people are often quite
reluctant to do that and we might see
quite a slow change there but the point
is you can still eat your beef burger
and you but you could like we could we
could half beef consumption if we just
did a half and half burger and people
would probably not really notice the
difference the texture would probably be
the same The Taste would pretty much be
the same I mean it would be a very very
quick way to do it and should really
have no impact on kind of uh
people's uh enjoyment of the
food and what would you you say to
someone who said look you've you know
you told you told us that everything's
basically going to be fine as long as we
do a bit of this and that you know we'll
have chicken burgers instead of beef
burgers and uh we'll install some more
solar panels and you are fundamentally
missing the point the point here is uh
economic growth is is unsustainable
fundamentally unsustainable a current
model is totally broken and degrowth is
what we need we actually need to shrink
the world population and we need to
shrink the world economy that is that
would be the push back from um not from
not generally from economists like me
but certainly the push back from a lot
of environmentalists what's what's your
response to that yeah again I get the
intuition there I think there are really
different I guess flavors of degrowth
what I'm quite explicit about in the
book is that we can't go for Global
growth right the world is too poor for
us to start to try to shrink the global
economy like if you do that you leave
billions of people in poverty now
there's a different question of should
we deliberately try to reduce
consumption and shrink in rich countries
which seems more
feasible um my one unless you're a
politician then feasible at all yeah I
mean yeah that's my one of my my my core
points is that um I just don't think
that messaging is ever going to get
through politically like I cannot see a
politician standing up and winning an
election with that as one of their key
slogans and I think the the time
component there is really important like
I think many of the the push back I
would get often
from showing that the UK has increased
its GDP while reducing emissions so what
we call decoupling of these two metrics
the push back is that it's not happening
for fast enough and it's not happening
fast enough but I think my my my contest
towards people arguing that degrowth
would be a better way of doing that is
what is the time scale for us to get to
a place where a politician is willing to
stand up um go for that as a core
message people to vote for them and then
actually put that into practice you're
not that's not going to be a fast
process um so the argument seems to me
to fall apart if you're trying to argue
that decup L is not going to happen fast
enough degrowth will also not happen
fast enough now another key part of the
argument of degrowth is that maybe it's
less about GDP and we can just reduce
energy use and in some sense yeah I
think there's many areas where we can
reduce energy use but a core part of
moving to low carbon economy is when we
go through the energy transition that
will happen anyway our current energy
system based on fossil fuels is
incredibly
inefficient um 2ir of the the the the
energy we we we burn is wasted like it
doesn't go towards actually our Energy
Services so moving us around powering
our homes and our and our laptops like
as wasted as heat so when you
decarbonize the economy you take away
most of that waste so your final energy
demand is going to be much much lower
anyway so we are actually going to
reduce energy demand anyway we're not
going to have to produce this massive St
of energy that we are producing today
and we still get the same welfare
benefits that we all want so to me I
think just a much better messaging
strategy for this is look we can
actually tackle both of these things at
the same time and I just don't think
that we're going to make any progress if
we try to frame it as we need to shrink
the economy in order to tackle climate
change we're nearly running out of time
but if if you are game I wanted to
finish up by by asking you to play
around of overrated and underrated this
is a game game game My my friend The
Economist Tyler Cowan likes to play so
I'm going to I'm going to tell you some
stuff and I want you to tell me whether
you think they're overrated or
underrated and if you fancy offering a
sentence or two of explanation then then
by all means but let's go for it okay
vertical Farms overrated like they just
consume so much energy it's just not
economically feasible and it would just
wreck the planet okay
chicken underrated I think a lot of
people push uh like have a resistance to
being told to eat less meat from a
climate perspective you can actually do
a substitution of meat and have a big
impact so if you substituted beef for
chicken so if you got rid of your beef
burger and had a chicken burger instead
it would have a massive reduction in
your climate impact okay going palm oil
free
overrated um Paro is a problem but it's
potentially less of a problem than the
Alternatives um so I think the strategy
there is not to boycott and get rid of
it I think it's to um produce more
sustainable Supply chains okay um hybrid
cars like plugin hybrids
yeah um a few years ago I would have
said underrated I'm now overrated I
think we can just go fully battery
electric okay and paper
straws oh overrated oh there just
terrible like paper and water should not
go together I don't know who thought
that was a good idea yeah we don't
actually need straws at all do we I
guess it's the but there we go um but
what we do need what we do need is this
book not the end of the world it's it's
fantastic Margaret atw loves it I love
it and we're very grateful to Hannah
Richie for writing it and very grateful
to you Hannah for coming and joining us
on intelligence Square thank you so much
thanks very much I love the
conversation